mark were here kapow comic convention
and you've been having various panels
today haven't you tell us a little bit
about one of them which is in particular
Miller world and well somebody actually
said on Twitter last year which I
thought was hilarious was the Kapoor was
what the world it'd be like if I was
Hitler and as and actually that is a
vaguely fascistic look to the police Lee
we need to see the mellow bottled air
with my name through the middle of it
and open it just seems like some
horrible parallel reality but I have
destroyed half the planet but it's
actually at the same time it's also
laughlin evidence had a great time in my
pals were on the panel you know Dave
Gibbons and Frank Quitely and natural
vigeland or who had that super trucks
worth and it's just just really fun and
it was lovely mid 700 people or
something in the hole so you know when
you do these things from home setting
working on you and you know is quite
nice to think that a lot of people
enjoying it and conventions are quite
nice affirmations about you he mentioned
super crooks then I talked to not show
earlier and he was telling me a little
bit about what you working together tell
us a bit more about that project well
natural and I it's funny actually
because it just all happened so quickly
you're not like natural I'd come up with
this idea of you know there's that very
simple idea of why the supervillains
overs you know do robberies in Gotham
City when Batman is so brilliant you
know and he's just going to quit if he
doesn't do it that says she's doing into
ashes time you're in prison you know and
I thought why not just go somewhere
where the cops are all quite lazy like
speed or something like it and it's good
to be there's no superheroes you can rob
that bank just fine and you know and I
worked out this plot for it another
thing and I was tailing someone about it
you know and like we ended up getting it
picked up really quickly from the guys
that had wanted with Lamar Platt
productions and I love those guys over
there just really good blogs and they
said be any idea for a director and I
said actually naturally Galan does a
good friend of mine he's a brilliant
Spanish director because you ever get to
do an english-language movie so I
suggested them and that just always
what's around that two million euros can
a budget and this is very much a 40
million plus can remove it and I was
wondering you know maybe one some guy
who's used to blockbusters or something
and it was a new noble of her stuff and
I think it's a kind of Duncan Jones
thing where you know that there's guys
good if you can do that for small budget
thing where you can do with a big budget
so I'm sorry bit excited about that and
they said the gym like natural like to
write the screenplay and I'm not a
screenwriter and have no ambition to be
a screener and natural can't speak
English barely you know and yet we spent
two weeks loving in my
it's right in the screenplay and what's
a very good you know so not just get
this movie is going to do first and
hopefully we'll get around to this next
year see what was it like stepping into
the role of a screenwriter thanks
obviously obviously a seasoned writer
and I actually a much prefer doing
comics much prefer a phone I've been
offered so many things and I turn
everything down and comics is just my
first love you know it's like it is such
a brilliant job like when I was five I
didn't want to be a screenwriter I
wanted to be a comic writer and I used
to hand draw my own comics IQs the one
being an artist as well and I used to
literally draw eight peach comics and I
didn't know photocopiers existed so they
never draw the same comic out perfectly
again you know luke and I would do maybe
five or six coffees like that and when I
found four coppers it was amazing I used
to do them and sell them had grown my
neighbors and sell them these little 5p
comics you know so that was my lifetimes
ambitions so to be doing this now I
don't see the stepping-stone to
something else so didn't screenplay I
was enjoying it and I loved what can be
natural but my mind was always can I
can't wait to go back and do panels
again and everything that that world is
very comfortable for me you know and joe
carnahan and i are going to create
something in october but but that's the
only screenplays on really ever planet
what's the kind of timeline for for that
particular film super croaks no super
cruise really just see what happens we
naturally you know they care I mean I've
done my bet really you know that I
couldn't that's getting play with them
probably bringing someone else and I'd
imagine to do our polish you know
because like I say natural Spanish I can
barely speak English you know so to get
someone who with a good asp of language
to commit and actually I ain't in it and
but there's plenty of time because
natural is going to spend at least the
next six nine twelve months or less
windows project and will probably get
around a super cruise next year
you